Okay. I realize it's reading period.
So we're supposed to be having fun.
So the structure of glucose is really fun.
Uh,
I originally had this lecture mostly
about the synthesis of two unnatural
products. These last two lectures are
going to be where to be about synthesis,
one about unnatural products and
one about natural products. Um,
but glucose is such a great story
that I couldn't miss telling it.
So we might not get to the synthesis of
two on natural products or I might just
mention it at the end. Uh,
it's also a Nobel prize work,
but so is the structure of glucose and
there are no bell prizes and Nobel prizes,
but the structure of glucose
is a really great Nobel prize.
Okay. So we saw last time
that their carbohydrates,
and I found who used the word first, it
was a guy named Schmid and 1844 he said,
meb allowed to denote compounds
with carbon plus hydrogen
and oxygen in the same
ratio that obtains in water
as carbohydrates. That is,
it doesn't have to be one to one,
one carbon to one water. So, uh,
there were examples,
known light grape sugar was isolated
pure in 1792 and it was given by do the
name glucose, which comes from the Greek
word glucose, which means sweetness.
Okay? So that's where glucose came
from. But even more important,
the OSC ending,
which is just part of the word glucose,
came to be the generic
ending for all showrunners.
So when you say something owes, that means
it's one of these carbohydrates. Hey,
and we remember that Cooper,
as soon as structure became something
that you could talk about because of the
Tetra Valence of carbon,
he proposed that there was another water
added to give the hydrate of glucose,
which is just fine. That would still
be a carbohydrate. And he was right,
right?
So you can have owl doses
like glucose where you hit,
where you take hydrogens,
two hydrogens from the top
carbon put them on either end.
So you have an Aldehyde or
you can do the next car,
but or the next carbon and get ketones.
So you can have ketosis, for example,
fructose as a kito. Some
glucose is an Aldehyde. Uh, now,
how do you know this? Uh, of course,
nowadays we know the structure of
things by spectroscopy. For example,
here's the IIR spectrum of glucose.
This Aldehyde,
what do you notice specially
about this spectrum? Anything?
What would you look for if you're
looking for the, for, for a sugar,
you'd look for Oah groups. Sure
enough, big goal. Each peak.
And you look for what other group?
Yeah.
And Tanya,
the Aldehyde. Carbondale. And where
would you look for, do you remember?
You look for it around 1700 and
it's not there or could do the Nmr.
So here's the Proton Nmr of crystal and
glucose. You dissolve it in d two o.
So now you don't have the
Oah protons there. Uh, uh,
and there's the Proton Nmr spectrum. And
again, there's no way down field peak,
no Aldehyde,
or if you look at the carbon NMR spectrum,
no downfield peak for Aldehyde
or ketone either. Right?
They would both come down
there and the carbon spectrum,
of course there wouldn't be a
hydrogen on the, on the ketone. Okay.
Now, um, so look,
let me draw it to try to explain this.
Draw it in a funny con formation,
which could be an equivalent
equilibrium with a Hemi key. Tau.
Remember with either acid or
base Qatar Alesis in water here.
Deuterated water. You could make a Hemi
key towel down here at the bottom, right?
Okay, so all the o's are ods,
right? But here you have ages.
Now let's blow up that part of the Nmr
spectrum that that you can see there.
And what peak stands out,
the one far down field,
what's it do to
which of the hydrogens in this compound
should come the furthest down field?
Hi,
has national what?
They all have the note.
Uh, the one here you mean? Yeah.
Now that one is on a carbon that
has two carbons attached to it.
Add an oxygen right?
And oxygen's,
withdraw tend to shift things down field.
Can you do better than that?
There's one oxygen to withdraw
from that carbon, right,
Megan,
right? The equatorial one, the
one at the far right, right.
Has Two oxygens pulling on it. The
one that's on a Hemi Ke Tau, right?
So it's way down field. Now notice
that there's a little peak here.
A little doublet. What's that do to? Well,
it could be just impurity, but it's not,
because if you let it sit a day,
it grows and the other one shrinks.
Right. It's also down field. Right.
So it looks like it's got more oxygens on.
Anybody got an idea?
Wow.
What did you call this one,
Megan? Suppose it had been axial,
right?
Then if you had a ring current
as in benzene,
you don't hear this one would be downfield
and the one where it was axial would
be upfield more over the top of the
ring. Right? Can you get it there?
Yeah, you can go back here and attack
the carbon eel from the other side.
Right. And get that one. Now
how do you know which is which?
How do you know which one was axial
on which one was that tutorial? Well,
you might use this argument about
written currents. People talk about that.
I'm not sure whether it means anything.
There are other kinds of arguments you
could make that might have to do with
that too.
But one thing that's clear in the spectrum
is that there's a doublet splitting
here, which is about eight hertz
and a doublet splitting here,
which isn't even half as big.
So one is a big splitting and one is
a small splitting. Now, which one is,
what is it that splitting this hydrogen
Carl.
Um,
sometimes ideas are place with an age,
so there has to be another h on the
adjacent carbon. It's splitting that one,
right? So this a chair, and in this case,
this h here would be doing it.
Okay.
But one of them is a big splitting
and the other as a small splitting,
Sebastian,
you've got an idea.
I'm on there, right?
The top one is Auntie,
the other one is a ghost. So there's
much better overlap, Auntie then Gauche,
right? So this one is the
one that's Auntie, that's
the one with axial hydrogen.
And this is the one,
the one that came from the crystal.
So the crystal was all the same. You
dissolve it and it begins to equilibrate.
Right.
And ultimately has more of the more of
the Ecuadorian hoodie than of the axial
Odi. Right. And in fact,
if you look at the original
material just after you dissolve it,
it has a rotation of 112 degrees
optically accurate, right?
But after a day in d two O it's only 53
degrees because the other isomer is 19
degrees.
So people use that before there was
spectroscopy to try to figure out what the
ratio of the two was that equilibrium.
Okay.
Or if you really want to do it,
you do it by x Ray de Fraction.
And then you get Cartesian
coordinates for all the atoms.
That's what you do nowadays.
But the interesting thing and what
got a Nobel prize was not this,
it was how did they know?
How could they figure out what
the structure of glucose was?
Well,
a lot of sugars,
we're known in the last half of the
19th century when Vantiff road is, uh,
the German version of his book
in 1877 he mentioned a lot of,
of, uh, of sugars as
optically active. For example,
here he cites glucose.
He also cites love yellows and in
fact those both come from sucrose.
Sucrose is a more calm,
more complex sugar.
It's a key towel that has
two of them together, right?
But if you take them apart,
one of them is that one of them is
glucose and the other is Levia Los,
which is also called toast.
Do you know why it's called Levy lows?
What's Livo mean?
Actually the English word is
the same root left, right?
Livo is left. Dextro is right
in Latin, right? So it rotates.
This rotates right light to the left.
This rotates light to the right and it's
called dextrose also or Dextrin down
here.
Okay.
He also mentioned lactose and it was
found in 1876 that lactose treated with
acid gives also glucose,
but another one called Gal actose,
which comes from the Greek word for milk.
So it's called milk sugar in German.
So the lactose obviously came from milk,
5% of milk.
I think my weight is lactose sugar.
Okay.
Or there's stuff called Mannitol, which
came from Manna. They, they would, uh,
uh, slash the bark of flowering
ash trees around the Mediterranean.
And this stuff would ooze out
in which they called Manna.
And from that they got mad at all and
mannitol turns out to have these kinds of
Cho age groups that fat off was interested
in cause they made things chiral.
But notice and Mannitol,
the two ends are both ohs,
the Aldehyde on the end has been
reduced in this case. Right.
Or both ends can be oxidized,
right.
As in what's called sugar acid.
Right.
So you could have both ends be an
acid or you can have a rabbit knows,
uh,
which comes from was isolated
at 1873 from gum Arabic.
Right. A gum that came from Arabia.
You know, if you're an actor,
you've put your mustache on with gum
Arabic. I think he used to, anyhow,
I don't know. Uh, okay.
And in fact it was possible
to take mannitol and oxidize
it back to an Aldehyde.
That must've been a tough thing to do
because aldehydes or very hard to stop at
an Aldehyde.
But somehow in 1888,
they were able to get mannose or
maybe even maybe just a teeny,
teeny bit of man who's doing
that. Okay. So, so, uh, Aldehyde.
Okay.
So there were lots and lots of these
known and people fiddled around with them
and found out what you'd
get if you oxidize to what
you'd get, a free or reduced.
And so on and on comes
Heinrich, Kelly, Yani,
the hydrogen cyanide man,
right?
Because in this paper in 1855,
which fortunately I've translated here,
he says,
while a large number of compounds are
very easily formed upon oxidation of
Dextrose,
remember Dextrose is glucose.
It rotates light to the right by
dilute nitric acid or by halogens.
These molecules are retained six carbons
bound together in a chain under the
same conditions. Levia lows. The
other one that came from, from uh,
the other one that came from sucrose,
yield substances containing chains
with smaller number of carbons,
like glycolic acid or
inactive tartaric acid here.
That's Misa tartaric acid, okay. Here,
oxidation causes immediate
splitting of the molecule.
It breaks the carbon chain of fact,
which means that Levia Lowe's is a ketone.
So that the the,
so that glucose or dextrose has the,
an Aldehyde at the end of the chain
and you oxidize that to an asset.
But if you have a ketone in the middle
of the chain and you oxidize it,
you break the chain, right? Uh,
so it must be a ketose of some sort.
Bearing in mind further
the fact that love you,
Lowe's is transformed into man
a tall by nascent hydrogen.
Nascent means at the
time that's being born.
They had this interesting
idea that those days,
that w that when they dissolved
sodium and alcohol, it, uh,
it generated hydrogen,
right?
But this hydrogen was more reactive than
most hydrogen and could reduce things
that normal hydrogen
glass gas couldn't do.
So they said it was nascent hydrogen
that could do things. In fact,
of course it was, it was the metal
actually transferring electrons to the,
to the compound to be reduced.
But anyhow, he said, well,
if you do that with Levy Los,
you get man a tall,
which remember was the thing that has
o h on both ends of the chain. Right?
So it was possible to reduce
the, the, if it was a Ketose,
a ketone in the middle channel
already had alcohols on the end.
But if you reduce the ketone
to an alcohol, then you
got alcohols all the way.
Let's like man a tall,
which they got from that.
So one comes to the conclusion that love
yellows must be a judge to have one of
the following two constitutional formula.
Either CEO,
they can't be the first carbon.
That's the Aldehyde.
That's the one where you reduce it.
It doesn't break or oxidize,
it doesn't break the chain. You
just get an acid here. Uh, if you,
if it's a ketone here,
you break the chain.
If it's a ketone here
or you break the chain,
what if it's a key tone
on the next carbon down?
Okay.
Why didn't he consider that?
So it's the same as the same as the one
above, right? There are only two. Okay.
Ah, okay. So was it
one or is it too, okay.
So he goes on in the paper to say one
could hope to distinguish definitively
between one and the other formula.
By succeeding at adding Hcn
to the ketone radical level,
that level you lose love you Lowe's and
transforming the Cyan hydrogen into the
corresponding carboxylic acid.
So you had CN hydrolyze it.
So at Coh it adds to the carbonyl carbon.
So it from compound one,
you would get this I had in CN here
and turn it into carboxylic acid from
compound to you from the ketone on the
next position down Uday ad here and get
that carboxylic acid. Okay. So, uh, then,
so the question is if you take,
if it has this structure,
then you add HTN Hcl,
you get this and it's very concentrated
Hcl we used incidentally or uh,
or if it's the next one down, you get
this. Okay. So you'd do it and decide,
all you have to know is which product
you get. Get it pure, see what it is.
The problem is these things as almost
all things are in sugar chemistry are
Syrup's, right? It's very, very,
very difficult to get crystals from them.
So it was really hard in
those days to purify things.
Nowadays you could do chromatography
maybe or something like that,
but then it was essentially impossible.
So they had to try to make things simpler
so that they could so that they had a
chance of crystallization.
He says it must on exhaustive reduction
by concentrated Hii yield methyl butyl,
a Siddique acid. So this
one, the one on the top,
we'd give methyl beautiful acetic
acid reduced with Hii and phosphorous.
And on the contrary,
the carboxylic acid from compound to
would give ethyl propyl a Siddique acid.
So all you have to do is know which
of these you've got a, and he said,
this is fine.
He said this does not.
But when he did the reaction
and got the product,
which should be either this or this,
he says it does not agree
with the description that
hex to gives of the calcium
salt of methyl butyl acidic acid.
So heck t said,
had done a lot of good work
on this compound, including
making the calcium salt.
He was able to crystallize the calcium
salt as a product he got and it didn't
degree with Hecht, right? So he says, uh,
which means that my hip to know AIC
acid is identical with ethyl propyl,
a Siddique acid.
So this is the one he's got,
but that compound wasn't known so he
couldn't be sure about it. Right? Uh,
but anyhow, he concluded that it must
be this since it's not hex compound.
Uh,
now the next year he,
in 1886,
he reacted
Ethel as Ceto acetate.
So this is a acid group
on a CD, Esther, right.
What's special about those hydrogens?
Active methylene adjacent
to two carbon goes,
you make the anti and you
can put an art group on,
you can make the anti and again,
put another art group on.
So we put on methyl, he put on
beauty or put on Ethel, pardon me?
Put on propyl. Right. And then what we,
what I told you last time is
that when you hydrolyze this,
you get the acid and
then it decarboxylated.
So from the a cdot, a cdot,
acetic ester synthesis,
you Lucio too and get a ketone.
But he did it differently in those days.
He used really,
really strong Koh,
which doesn't give a ketone,
it gives assets,
it gives acetate that is you at
the hydroxide attacks here. Uh,
CDEC acid comes off
generating that an eye on,
which then picks up a
proton from the SCT Casad.
So you say you have acetate and the,
and a and an acid at ion,
right?
Which you then put a proton
on and you got this right.
So he made authentic stuff,
but it wasn't,
didn't agree with what
he got from love yellows.
So now from Hackney knows it wasn't this,
and from his own work,
he knows it's not that.
So now he began to wonder about
Hecht and just how good Hecht was.
Right?
So he went on and did the same thing,
putting on methyl and
butyl to make this right.
And he compared it with the product from
this and found that the calcium, barium,
strontium and lead salts all agreed in
their properties. So Hecht was wrong.
He said at the end of the paper that
Hector's going to go back and look at this
a little more, but at any rate, he was
then able to prove that, that, that, uh,
love yellows or fructose
has that structure.
The carbon eel is in the second position,
so he's,
he now knows the constitution
of fructose. Okay. Uh,
then he talks this paper from 1887 is
on the composition and constitution of
Arab Barrick acid and Arabah knows,
so now he's going to look
at a different sugar, right?
And what he says is in a report
dated 27, November, 1886,
I showed on the one hand that Arrow,
Barrick acid formed by oxidation
of Arabah knows, has the,
the formula show in there. But on the
other hand described several derivatives,
Urbanova's carboxylic acid
with the formula c seven.
So it was uncertain whether Arabah knows,
had a rabid knows,
was uh, was uh, uh,
a five carbon sugar or a six carbon sugar
if a five carbon sugar and he oxidized
that he'd get five carbons.
If it was a six carbon sugar and he
added a HCN to add another carbon,
he would get c seven.
So here he says,
he admits that he had
said contradictory things.
One that implied that it was [inaudible]
another that implied it was the six.
Since at that time I had no basis in
truth to dispute the generally accepted
formula for revenues,
which is that it c six,
the analyses are very similar
to one another, whether it's,
whether it's one or the other.
And my analytical results did
not contradict either assumption,
so he couldn't be sure whether Arabah
knows the stuff that came from gum Arabic,
uh, was c five or c six, right?
So we took Arabah knows he added HCN.
Uh,
he made the Arabah knows carboxylic acid.
This stuff that you've
talked about up there. Uh,
but he said then it was c seven here. He
made it with one, two, three, four, five,
six. Here he made the six assuming
that it starts with five. Right.
And he was able to reduce that with sodium
and Merck sodium with mercury to get
Mannitol, which was
known to be c six. Right?
So it was clear that [inaudible] wasn't
a c six sugar, it was a c five sugar.
So he had resolved this.
Okay.
But it was pointed out that it was one
of the reasons it was difficult to work
with this,
with this original compound was a mixture.
Why would it be a mixture?
Because the cyanide could add to either
face of this carbon right to make,
right. Or left handed carbon. Right.
And these other carbons
are of course chiral too.
So you get diastema reimbursed
depending on which side you add from.
This was pointed out by someone who
was very sensitive to not just the
constitution,
the sequence of bonds,
but to configuration of of these sugars,
which is going to make a lot of
difference with so many chiral centers,
they're going to be lots of isomers.
So the person who pointed
that out was Emile Fisher,
who was three years older than Kili Yani
and died much sooner for reasons you'll
see. Uh, so what he was,
one thing he did with Kelly on his acid,
right?
This is the acid you get by adding
CN to the five carbon sugar and then
hydrolyzing it.
So Kelly Yani treats treated with
sodium and mercury and got a man at all.
But Fischer did something different.
No, bear in mind, this is a reduction.
So you'd take the acid all
the way to the alcohol.
It's very difficult to
stop at the Aldehyde.
But Fisher found a way
to stop at the Aldehyde,
which was the first heat it to
make this lactone a cyclic Esther,
and then reduce that with sodium and
mercury. And now he got the Aldehyde here.
Now why was that handy?
Because it gave away to convert
one sugar into another sugar.
Now you could make new
sugars synthetically because
it was possible to stop at
the Aldehyde,
right?
So Achille Yani Fisher
synthesis on a rabbit knows,
gave this compound.
So he,
so Kilimani Fisher synthesis elongates
and Al Dose makes it one carbon longer.
Okay. Now that wasn't the reason
Fisher got the Nobel prize.
Uh,
a contributing factor was fennel
hydrazine when he was a graduate student,
he synthesized fennel hydrazine and
he loved to make derivatives with it.
Remember we talked about how you make
derivatives of carbonyl compounds with n n
things to make, uh, uh,
to make him mean bonds and they're very
strong if you have two ends together
like that. So, uh, he, he
could do it with sugars,
right? So you could, you could react
with the sugar and make an Emmy.
It's called a hydra zone.
Right now this hydrogen here is al.
So it could shift up to here
and make the double bond here.
But now this hydrogen is Al Lilly
and it could shift to there.
So you can get this. Now
you've got another key tone.
So what's going to happen?
So you can take an,
make another hydro zone,
right?
So now you've used the second mole of,
of a fennel hydrazine, right?
So now that one's out, Lilly,
you can shift it over here. And I
think I did too. Oh No, no, sorry.
Uh,
this here we do a sick lick rearrangement.
This hydrogen goes to that nitrogen.
This bond breaks this.
These electrons go here to make a double
bond, becomes a single double right?
So it breaks apart into two
molecules, one of which leaves, right?
And now we have a c n double bond,
which is very like a CEO double bond.
So you can get a third molecule of fennel
hydrazine to react and make a CN new
CN double bond,
losing ammonia.
And you get this compound that has two
of his favorite molecules stitched in
there. It's called an Osa zone. It's a,
it's a hydro zone that's made
from a knows from a sugar. Okay.
So unfortunately, so, so he could make,
by treating this with a,
with his favorite compound,
you could make this now it
was his favorite compound,
but it's also deadly poisonous.
And he poisoned himself very
badly for almost a decade.
He was in very bad health because of
poisoned himself with this. And in fact,
in 1919 he committed suicide.
He had cancer at the time.
And who knows whether it might've
been had to do with exposure to is his
favorite molecule.
But if it was so dangerous and
he knew he was being poisoned,
why did he like it so much?
It was because Osa zones are Crystalyn.
Remember these sugars are always syrup's
and you can't do anything with them.
But with crystals you could,
you could purify and tell what things
were tell with one thing is the same as
something else or different.
So that was the beauty for him of,
of fennel hydrazine that you could make
an ozone and identify things and in a,
in sugar chemistry. Okay. Now,
so he was interested in the,
uh,
in identifying the
structures of these things.
So let's try to be systematic about
seeing what the configurations could be.
Different sugars. Okay, let's
look at the hexoses. We, oh,
we already have a wreath.
Rose Arabah nose and Zilo
Serranos came from gum.
Arabic.
Zillow's came from wood era.
Throws comes from a,
comes from a lichen.
A riff means red in Greek.
So arithe rose came was because
it came from this red plant. Okay.
But there are also hexoses glucose,
mannose,
galactose and ghouls.
And all these were identified by
killing Yonnie as being aldoses,
right? Aldehydes, not ketones. We showed
how he could tell the difference there.
So these must differ in their
configuration right now.
How many should there be if you
have six carbons in the chain,
that ends in a hell to hide.
How many should there be? Well,
for this purpose we could write them all
out like this. This is a particular one.
Using what projection?
The Fischer projection.
And the,
one of the most amazing things about
Fisher is that he figured this all out
without having the Fischer projection.
It's easy for us to trace his thought
now using the Fischer projection.
But he used van Hoff's notation, which
was very, very complicated. And I, I,
I have never figured it out.
Right?
So that's one of the real triumphs of
Fisher was to be able to think through
this stuff without Fisher projections,
which he published the next year.
Okay.
But instead of what we could abbreviate
that Fischer projection by writing it
that way.
Oops,
I wrote at the wrong here it's these
lines show which way the OAH point.
So it's always the bottom. You don't care.
It's not chiral. The next one, the Ooh,
the right, Ooh, to the right. That
would should be Ooh to the left. Ooh,
to the right.
So the code is clear.
Now we can just write out all the,
all the possibilities.
So we have, there are three
chiral carbons. All right?
Uh, uh, no. Pardon me? Uh,
yeah, there, there are no
there, therefore chiral carbons.
So they're going to be 16
possible isomers. Right?
But if we're looking only at the d sugars,
those are the ones that are all
to the right on the bottom right.
We could draw that mirror
image to the El sugars.
But let's keep it simple just by showing
the d sugars. Because as Fisher, well, no,
well knew he had no way of
telling Dee from Al Right?
You could measure the rotation,
but not the absolute configuration.
So let's just assume that that a given
compound is deep in the d series.
Okay? Now how can you draw them all out?
You can draw, right? Right, right, right.
Left, left, left, left. Then
you can go right, right, left,
left, right, right, left, left,
and finally right, left, right,
left, right, left, right, left.
You've got eight isomers and four
of them most w busbee glucose,
mannose,
galactose on Boulos but not [inaudible].
Zilo is because as we just saw a kill,
Yani showed that her revenues was a five
carbon sugar, not a six carbon sugar.
It's a pentose and arithe rose
is a Tetros, a four carbon sugar.
And finally at the top you
have glycerin Aldehyde,
the one that Fisher chose as the
reference for what's d? Okay,
so the question only is which is which?
And at first dance glanced,
that looks impossible until you come along
with ex-ray or Nmr maybe or something
to figure out.
But fish figured it out.
So here was the evidence he used.
And you can look online on the website
and see the translation of his paper,
how he actually did it.
Almost all textbooks,
a nod and uh, and cover
this a little bit. Uh,
uh, because that's realized what a
great contribution. It wasn't, man,
it's like Shakespeare or something
like that, but they all mess it up.
They use modern reagents. They say it
should have worked this way or something.
This is what Fisher actually did. So
you could read about it. But anyhow,
this is the evidence he used.
He found that glucose could be oxidized
by nitric acid to make the compound that
is an asset on both ends of the chain.
So it's symmetrical with respect to asset.
Okay.
Not just the Aldehyde,
but also the primary alcohol got oxidized
to an acid and then he did his heating
to make a lactone and
reduce it with sodium,
which made it back into a sugar again.
Okay.
And the sugar,
he got what he called Boulos.
It's different from what he started with.
You'd think if you,
if you oxidize and then reduce back again,
you've got the same
thing you started with,
but he could get a different
sugar this way. Why?
How could it be different?
Could be. The aldehyde was
on the top, made two acids
reduce the top to an alcohol
and the bottom two an Aldehyde.
So now it's upside down so
you'd have to rotate it. Okay.
So it could be a different one of these
sugars that we drew on the last slide.
Okay. And he decided to
call it Google Lowe's. Why?
It's a sort of an anagram. It reverses
the you and the l glucose school lows.
Right, because he wanted an
for end. So he, you know,
chemists sometimes have sort of
geeky senses of humor, right?
So Boulos.
Okay,
so that was the first evidence and
then subsidiary evidence to that.
Is that the acid,
the dye acid he got on the way is chiral
and both enantiomers of it were known.
Okay.
That's the first line of evidence.
The second line of evidence is that
glucose and mannose give the same ozone.
Remember he made Osa
zones to make crystals,
but glucose mannose gave the same one.
Also are rabid knows if you
do a [inaudible] reaction
gives two different acids.
Gluconic and [inaudible] acid.
We talked about that before,
that it can add either side and fructose
when it's reduced to give alcohols all
along the chain gives two different
alcohols. Calusa tall and man a tall,
and notice all of these are glucose
related and mannose related.
So there's some special relationship
between glucose and mannose that all three
of these things do that. And the
second line of evidence is man at all.
And monodic acid acid are chiral.
So if you have o h is on both
ends or acids on both ends,
it's chiral. Okay. Bear in
mind that this, you know,
people were just fiddling around and
seeing what they could make from what,
but fish collected the key items of
evidence that could be used to make a real
logical argument.
Okay,
so third Arabah knows when he did Akil,
Yani Fisher Synthesis gave glucose,
but also it gave mannose,
right? That we've seen.
This relationship became
Glucan man and Zilo goes,
which was all, which came from
wood. That's the Xylophone, right?
Zilo would sugar by the [inaudible]
fissure synthesis added a carbon and made
Boulos. Remember this one up
here? And also another compound,
which I think is one
called [inaudible] now,
but that turns that these aren't
really relevant. Okay. But then three,
a Arabah knows if you make two [inaudible]
or two carboxylic acids on each end
is optically active,
but Zilo skiffs inactive compounds with
Oah on both ends are acid on both ends.
In fact, that was tough because
a rabbit tall has no rotation.
You put it in and you think it's not
chiral, right? But if you add, uh,
if you add a boric acid,
then it rotates light.
Remember, it's hard to know what causes
rotation. And it just happens that,
that our rabbit tall has no rotation
on measurably small rotation.
Right?
But if you make a derivative of it,
then you can see that
and the acid is rotate.
So it required a lot of work
to know these things for sure.
So that's the evidence and therefore he
knows what glucose is and what all the
others are. That's pretty much
of an accomplishment, right?
Just just to conceive that on
the basis of this evidence,
you could figure it out is amazing.
And this is only 10 years,
15 years after van Hoff
proposed the tetrahedral carbon.
A lot of people still
didn't believe in it.
Okay,
so here are the, here are the hexoses
and Penn Todos pentose is said,
we're going to go through his lines of
evidence and see how his logic worked.
Okay,
so evidence one was that glucose gives a
dye acid and on heating and reducing it
gives Boulos.
So when you turn it end for end,
right?
Then you've got a different compound.
Okay? So let's go across and
see, would that be true of this?
If you turned it end for end,
would it be a different compound?
You remember what the Fischer projection,
the ideas things turn out at you.
So you could, you can't rotate 90
degrees, but you can rotate 180 degrees.
So if we rotate that on this one, 180
degrees, do we get the same thing again?
That is if we made the dot on the bar.
What you do here with this is make a
dot on the bottom and not on the top.
So then you have to rotate it to bring
it back into this series that we've drawn
here. Right. Obviously those
would all point to the left.
It would be the mirror image and
the one we started with. So, uh,
that's, we'll put that on the back burner
for a second. Okay. How about, oops,
I went ahead too fast. How about the
next one? If you turn that in for end,
does it look the same? If you put
the dot on the bottom and rotate it?
Obviously different. Is everybody
with me on it's been different.
That would will be different. This
one, however, will be the same,
right? If you rotated the 180 degrees,
it's going to be left, left, right, right.
Again, if you change top
to bottom and rotate. Okay,
so that one is not, that one is not
glucose, nor is it Google close.
Okay. Because if you rotate in for
is different, how about the next one?
Will that be different? Should we
take it out? That'll be different.
That will that be different? Ah, that's
going to be the same. Not Different.
Right. So we can take that
one out. How about the next
one? Will that be different?
That's going to be like the first one
where everything that's right's going to
be left. Everything that's
left is going to be right.
So we'll put that in a bay ins for awhile.
And the last one also is different.
So from item one, we know for sure that
it's not that and not that glucose.
Now item one a and we're not so confident
about that because it changes the hand
in this only, but the, as
the dye acid is chiral.
Both enantiomers are known when
the two ends are the same. Okay.
So with this one, if you, if the two
ends were the same, would it be Kyrell?
No, it would have a horizontal plane
of symmetry through the middle.
So it can't be that one, right? This
one, would that have a plane of symmetry?
No. No. That one's out
already. How about that one?
No. How about that one?
Ah, that one's out.
That wouldn't be chiral. The last one
would be chiral. Okay. So from one a,
we know it's not, we confirmed that
it's not that and it's not that. Okay,
so we're down to four candidates
for what could be glucose.
Now we go to item two,
glucose and mannose give the same ozone.
Remember what the ozone did it,
it made a double bond at the top carbon
and a double bond at the next carbon.
So that means this next carbon
here isn't chiral anymore. Right.
And if you take a rabid knows,
start with,
with that being the carbon eel and ed CN,
it can add to either side.
One would give that,
one would give that if you had to,
depending on what our revenues is, one
would give this, this one would give that,
that one would give that that.
So again,
it says they differ only at
this second carbon and fructose,
which has a ketone at the second carbon
as Kilian he showed gives to alcohols.
So could give this alcohol and that
alcohol is alcohol, that hot call, so on.
So anyhow, what that means
is you disregard that. Okay.
So this item two shows that the,
that glucose and mannose
differ only in this carbon.
So now when we look at
that, uh, evidence too,
we know that if this is
glucose, this is mannose, right?
They differ only at that carbon, which
this shows is not relevant here, okay?
So if this is glucose, this is madness.
If this is glucose, what's mannose?
This one, right? If this is glucose,
this is mannose.
And if this is glucose,
this is mannose, okay? That's
what evidence to shows, okay?
Now, evidence to a, is that mannitol? Ooh,
on both ends or acid on both ends.
Those molecules are chiral.
So can this be mannose if the two
ends of the same as it handed?
No. So, so this can't be glucose.
Okay? How about this? If
this, could this be mannose?
If the two ends of the same,
will it be chiral?
No, it doesn't have a
mirror in the middle, right?
That one doesn't have a mirror in
the middle, right? It's a propeller.
It's not a chiral.
The one that's right at the top and left
at the bottom is the mirror image of
this not identical to it. Right? So
it could, it could still be that,
uh, could this be mannose? Yes.
That means this could be glucose.
Could, could this be mannose?
No, because now it has a mirror in
the middle, so that can't be glucose.
Okay. So from two a then we can
exclude this and we can exclude that.
Okay.
So one of these must be glucose and the
other one is Google owes the one that's
turned in for end top to bottom.
Okay.
So how are we going to decide that?
Or how did fish decided
he went to evidence three,
which is Urbanova's and the kill Yani
Fits Fisher Synthesis gives glucose and
Zilo skiffs Boulos right.
So one of them gives one of these and
the other one gives the other one of
those.
Okay.
So we know something now about
a rabbit Rabideau in silos.
They can't be this and they can't be
this because that on Achille Ronni Fisher
said this is,
couldn't give either of these and this
couldn't give either of those. Right.
So those are out for, that one's out and
that one's out for revenues and silos.
Okay.
But what we know from evidence three is
that if this is glucose that was had to
be Arabah knows the thing,
that you add another carbon
here and make that right.
And if this was glucose,
that would be a knows.
Okay. And vice versa. If it's
a rabbit, no sense glucose.
Okay. Now how are we going to,
so if we know our [inaudible],
which is a rabid knows on which is silos,
then we know which is goop glucose
in which is Boulos because of those
connections.
Okay.
So evidence three a is a rabid knows,
gives optically active Arabah
tall and Arabic acid. Okay.
When the two ends of the same,
it's chiral.
Xylos is not chiral when the
two ends of the same. Okay.
Could this one be Arabah knows? Would it
be chiral if the two ends of the same,
how about that one? No. Okay,
so that one's got to be a rabid knows
by three and that one's got to be silos.
Okay?
So we know that glucose can't be this
because it comes from [inaudible].
So that one is glucose.
So he proved it.
Okay. Now, so all of these that
all of these known compounds,
all these known compounds where that
assigned, if you knew this was glucose,
then you knew that was Boulos.
You know the glucose mannose
differ only at this carbon.
So you know which man is his,
you know,
which are Rabideau says which is ilo
is you also can figure out which one or
with rose is by making
Arab Reno's from it. Right?
So all of these things now work,
it's like the end of a solitaire game
when everything begins to work. Right?
Okay. So you now you get all the other
sugars in fact of these 16 sugars,
the right and left handed
ones in the bottom row,
the exos of the 16 Fisher made 13 of
them himself and he made 50 artificial
sugars overall in the
1890s 1880s 1890s okay.
So we got others, like he also
got three Oh's. How did it,
so this was a new compound,
how did he name it?
Where did the name three Oh's come from?
It's a riff rose turn around, right?
Sort of turned around or he got
ribos like ribonucleic acid.
DEOXYRIBONUCLEIC acid.
Where does the name Ribos come from?
From Miravich knows from gum
Arabic or he got licks. Sows.
That's pretty obvious.
Or he got Talos from galactose.
L. Okay. Or he got altros.
He was beginning to run out.
So this just means another one
alter. Right. Or he got out,
he got a dose.
That's idiom,
you know that the same as the
one above and a list. Is it m?
So it's another one, right. Or Allos,
which is the Greek version
of Altros. Right. Okay.
So he got all these and he got the
Nobel prize and he got the second Nobel
prize.
The first Nobel prize went to van Hoff.
Not for [inaudible],
but for his work in physical chemistry.
Right.
But the second Nobel Prize went to
[inaudible] via Fisher because everybody
realized what a great contribution.
You know, it's not just doing it but,
but doing it without Fischer
projections is a lot tougher.
It's to conceive that you can do it,
that the evidence is there,
that you apply this new theory that
Vantiff came up with not so long ago and
follow it through with,
with rigorous logic and you've got it.
Rather than just fiddling around
making this, making this, making this,
making this,
he puts it all together.
He finds the crucial bits of evidence
and puts them together to do this really
beautiful proof. So I thought you wanted
that, would want to know about that. Now,
uh, if you want to remember it,
the Guy who taught me organic,
I took organic chemistry the way you
are 50 years ago this year. Okay.
And the guy that I took it from
Louie are made up this all altruism.
It's gladly make gum in gallon tanks.
And I remember that for 50 years.
So I have no trouble doing aloes,
Altros Glucose, mannose school, Oci,
dose, collect, toasts, and Talos.
It's not a very fundamental
contribution to science,
but it's very handy if you
want to teach about hexoses.
And if you want to do this
one, it's Raxel, Ra XL
and arithromycin three. Oh,
you just remember, okay.
So Hooray for a hooray for anal fissure.
Uh,
now, uh, we got two minutes just to
show you, I'm not going to show you how,
how this happened, but it's going to
be a stream of consciousness thing.
You're not responsible for it on the exam,
but I've got all the slides here.
So what the hell? Right?
And it, it is a neat thing.
Okay. So we talked about Cyclo Buda
dying. Is it anti aromatic? Right?
Make it and see what its properties are.
The problem is that one of it,
so you can make it by
this shine light on it.
It closes up in a dis rotatory process
and then with light it can it the co two
and you get to get it.
So study its properties.
The problem is that it
undergoes a really quick,
a reaction with itself, a deals
alder reaction, which gives this,
and then that opens up.
It's because it's very strained of course,
and give cyclopedia Buda Diane. So
you get, or just Cyclo Octa Tetra.
And so you get cycle octa
Tetra in, which is sort of, uh,
sort of evidence that
you had Cyclo Buda dying,
but it's not like knowing its properties.
Okay.
So the problem is that
it reacts with itself.
So it's presumptive evidence of existence.
Could you do spectroscopy?
So you have to make it somehow
under conditions that it
won't react with itself.
So if you've made it inside a cage,
like a big clam shell,
so only one molecule was in there,
then it couldn't react with itself.
So they made this compound
with the guest inside,
so it's too big like a clam shell
and holds the precursor inside.
So there's a mouth that you
can put things in and out from.
And it was done by Donald Cram who
got the Nobel prize and Martin Tanner,
the son of Dennis Tanner,
who burned his eyebrows out with
the 4th of July demonstration.
They grew back again.
He was not permanently barred Thomas,
I don't know.
So they made,
these are groups were big things for,
to make it soluble and it was that,
and you can make that by thinking
backwards with an Algal reaction,
right?
So first they make the bottom half of
the thing and how to form this big ring
with 16 carbons in it,
right?
You take resource and all and
Hydro Cinnamon Aldehyde, right?
And then, uh, this is a good,
very active for
electrophilic substitution.
So he protonate that you have an
electric file, forms a bond Ortho Para,
you've got the first bond made,
put that in deep dehydrate,
you can react with another one.
So you've got another one now you just
keep doing it to make all those all the
way around. But you could imagine lots
and lots of different ways of doing it.
And it turns out that the electrophilic
aromatic subsidies is reversible.
And ultimately this compound,
the one they wanted to make,
this precipitates from the
equilibrating mixture in a 69% yield.
That is luck. Okay, so they, so this,
the fish jumped into this particular boat,
right?
But now they need these bonds across the
top of that bottom to the teeth for the
clam. Right. So what they
did is they put roaming on,
they made it into a,
then they, they made uh,
and ions here with bass
and reacted with ch two,
with two leaving groups.
So one leaving group,
the other leaving group and
now do it on all the others.
And you've got those carbons put in right
now you have to join the top half to
the bottom half, right? Uh,
Oh, they got this incidentally,
they didn't get a 69% yield.
That was 5% from the tetramer and
they had isolated by chromatography.
Okay. So now, uh, they had
to join the two hemispheres,
which they've put a lithium on
in place of, of the bromine.
And then they'd put Boron on.
And then hydrogen peroxide,
which we've seen before to
make those into alcohol's,
we've seen that before.
So you see,
this was really to be review
of stuff we've done. Okay.
So now you've got alcohols all the way up.
So he got the ows that are going to do
the bridging and now you just do that
same thing you did before,
uh,
to put a carbon in this carbon the same
way you did that one by having a low,
uh, carbon, uh, with, with two
halogens, so to leaving groups.
And now again, when those two things
come together, if you have, uh,
three things that can react here in
three things that react here that can go
like that, which is what you want, it
could go like that. It could go like that.
It could go like that. There are
lots of different ways, right? Uh,
but it turned out that he got,
they got 40% of it,
40% of this stuff went into that overall
after from this stuff you started and
it's a 1% yield,
but they started with a lot of stuff.
So they had the clam shell, right?
And now it turned out they could,
they could get the guests out.
This is a crystal structure.
So this stuff at the top is,
is a chloroform, which is,
and this is solvent,
they're two different solvents in there,
but in the middle of the cage is DMF held.
This is that clam shell here.
And these things are just put on to
make it soluble so you can work with it.
Okay. So they could get that stuff out
and they could replace it with, with this.
So here's that stuff on the cover of
Andrea Vonda Comey inside that compound,
and this is the Nmr spectrum.
So most of the peaks come from these
hydrogens in the Co, in the shell, right?
But the ones marked in red and one that's
under here are these four hydrogens on
the starting material. And
then they focalized it and
they got the purple peaks.
It changed, right? And then they,
they fertilize again and
they got just one peak.
That's the peak of cycle of Buddha die.
Right?
And it can't react with any others
because there are no others around.
And then if you, if you get it out
again, that will react to your cycle.
Ought the tetra heat.
So this is way up field,
anti aromatic,
as we talked about before.
Now is that what causes the upfield shift?
Because you'll notice something else.
If you put benzene inside,
its normal position would be here,
but benzene inside that
clam shell is there.
It shifted way up field.
Why?
Because it's above all sorts
of other benzene rings.
Remember when, uh, when, when you
have something above a benzene ring,
it's shifted up field. If it's out in
decided that shifted downfield but this,
the one that's in the middle is above all.
So some of that shift must be due to this
same effect that makes benzene go up.
So most of the shift comes
from the other rings.
Still about still it's about one and a
half parts per million above benzene.
So it is shifted up field and
his auntie aromatic. So that's,
I think that's what I wanted to show
you. That's the end. Okay. But the big,
the big lesson is how Fisher did glucose.
Thanks.